hi it's time for episode 2 of this
series and I'm actually gonna tell you
already in episode 3 I'm going to built
the first skyscraper and I'm telling
that right now just to tease you guys
because I'm so mean and I'm not actually
gonna build a skyscraper in this video
yet but I'm gonna build this building
which is still pretty cool I don't know
I kind of like this building actually
this is the the the high-class a
building that you probably saw already
on the thumbnails of the first videos
because I decided to take thumbnails of
things now I've already made which is
really stupid but it looks good so
whatever so I basically like every
single building in this city I just need
to come up on the spot with the design
of this so I figured I'm just gonna do
some glass shenanigans on the sides and
then add some like brick walls in the
middle with windows and hopefully it'll
look good and I guess it kind of turned
out into somewhat of a decent building I
don't know when it comes to modern
office buildings you can just while
realistically speaking you can just make
it either entirely out of glass or just
brick walls with the windows but I just
really like to mix it up because
especially in rollercoaster tycoon 3
since the textures and graphics aren't
all that great I do want some mixture
going on so definitely recommend just
using the brick walls and just the glass
as well I don't know I just really like
the look of it and I think I had some
some fun actually experimenting with
different things because obviously there
are some details on buildings which
which you should really pay attention to
and those details are the things on the
sides and on the top and on the bottom
so basically like these corner stones
right here just the things that you put
on the sides of the walls they don't
really make a difference to the shape or
entire look of a building but it just
makes a very small difference with well
considering how small the details are
and another important well thing like
that is also the boiler that you add on
top of the building and I think I
actually got quite a funny boiler for
this building
now of course these windows on the sides
is just very simple and this building
entirely is just a very simple structure
really it's just some brick stuff in the
middle which
glass on the site and that's pretty much
it it's not it's not even as detailed as
the first building I definitely need to
kind of do some more detailed stuff now
here what here I was messing with like
all of these colors and then I figured
now the building is too white so I just
decided to add some brick walls and that
actually really worked but I don't know
why but I just really love ending those
little accents like the Aqua accents
that I've added in this building I don't
know why but as you can see that
building on the front where I'm doing
the planters right now has the red
accents and I just feel like accents
like that really make details and
building as a whole stand out more and
here is once again me messing with
[ __ ] stuff that I need to put in
planters because that's always I don't
know something it's just sometimes
bothers me such a hassle sometimes and
then there's the top of the building or
fridge I at first figured I would make
that high but then I didn't have any
class on top of it so I made it 180
lower so I could actually have some
glass on top of it too because it just
looked kind of terrible and I feel like
it's okay the only problem that I have
with that building what I'm starting on
a new one already is the fact that from
the sides it looks it looks really good
so the narrow sides but from the front
where it's a lot wider it's maybe a bit
too boring now this building obviously
it's just very simple it's it's inspired
actually by the neoclassical Dutch
buildings which which have the brick
walls and the white stuff going on just
like American buildings do but this is
slightly more Dutch neoclassicism I
don't exactly know where the difference
is but it's mainly there in the roof and
the general shape of the building the
way that you have the pediments and all
that and the pillars of course or
blusters rather on the sides I don't
know I just really like classical
building so even though this is a modern
series I still find myself building them
and of course I'm still over using this
door every every damn time I still do
that I'm sorry about that but it's just
such an awesome door and I actually
really like this building I don't know
if anybody from Holland can really
recognize it but it's kind of like the
and the classical buildings that you
have in many of their big cities and
then I think I messed around with those
trim
but they never really came up well so I
just decided to discount that idea
altogether because damn it just looked
terrible and then I try to make this
street red and accidentally ended up
making that building red and well not
really red I didn't even know what you
call that color it I'm not that good at
colors but yeah I think I like this
trees like this and it adds a bit of
color but it's not too bright or too
weird for a street and speaking of
streets I definitely want to lay out a
simple plan of the city so I did I just
decided to go with the American way of
doing things straight everywhere but I
did want to add some turns or at least
not make everything a well a grid
pattern so that's why and it does
something that's why I decided to at
least add some variation in there and
yeah it's time for off-topic rent
because I don't I don't even know why
Americans do that that like straight
square Street pattern I don't like it I
just asked so it's so damn boring but
it's handy for all the co second three
because it really makes my job easy
because roller coaster cycling three is
a grid and all that so I'm not going to
complain about that but anyway in the
next episode I'm going to do that
awesome skyscraper at the end of the
road so see you then guys